größte leistungs und informationsschau
in kärnten zum nationalfeiertag am 26
oktober 2017 vom 9 bis 17 uhr am
rennbahngelände in sankt veit an der
glan höhepunkt und 10 uhr angelobung der
entkernten eingerückten rekruten das
österreichische bundesheer bietet an
diesem tag einen querschnitt aller im
bundesheer verfügbaren geräte und
ausrüstungen
es präsentieren sich alle kärntner
dienst stellen und verbände mit ihrem
spezialgerät somit ist für groß und
klein etwas dabei zum motto unser
einsatz ihre sicherheit sollen
informationen und mitmachen im
mittelpunkt stehen
zu sehen gibt es sowohl aktuelle
ausrüstung hubschrauber panzer sowie
historisches gerät und zahlreiche action
vorführungen der bevölkerung soll aber
vor allem das bundesheer als zentraler
sicherheitsfaktor für österreich und als
attraktiver und zukunftssicherer
arbeitgeber präsentiert werden
unverzichtbar für österreich sicherheit
bietet das bundesheer gemeinsam mit
vielen anderen blaulicht und
rettungsorganisationen an diesem tag ein
umfangreiches programm an form des
nationalfeiertags am 25 oktober wird
durch militärmusik kärnten der große
zapfenstreich des österreichischen
bundesheeres am rathausplatz aufgeführt
versuchen auch sie die größte leistungs
und informationsschau in kärnten zum
nationalfeiertag am 26
oktober 2017 von 9 bis 17 uhr am
rennbahngelände in sankt veit an der
glan